vladimir poutine dit constater une
aggravation de la situation dans l'est
de l'ukraine à donetsk dans cette région
du don parce que vous allez l'entendre
les sirènes ont retenti
signe consignes même donner aux
populations d'évacuer
les séparatistes pro-russes de lougansk
accuse kiev de préparer lé encore une
invasion et envisage même elle d'évacuer
les civils vers la russie culinaire
craquer notre envoyé spécial à accra
matos c'est dans cette région du dombass
dans une ukrainienne écouter
ici j'ai demandé quelle était la
réaction beau à cette annonce par les
leaders des sceaux lisant séparatistes
et nice co chine et tout le monde me
répondu et c'était surtout à dévêtir on
en fait des soldats vétérans de ce
conflit ils se pensent tous que c'est
pour les faits dénonce ils pensent tous
que ce n'est pas parce que il va
vraiment éclater une guerre de grande
envergure mais beaucoup plus pour
l'opinion publique en russie pour
retourner les russes contre les
ukrainiens pour que me disent écoutez
développer cette fiction d'un génocide
contre les habitants russophones du
donbass venant de la part de kiev donc
ils ont réagit vraiment avec un grand
flegme et j'essaie aussi de contacter
des gens qui étaient de l'autre qui sont
de l'autre côté de la ligne de front à
donetsk même et là ils disent que pour
le moment il ne se passe rien cette
annonce a été faite mais il n'y a pas de
convois qui commence à partir on leur a
communiqués rien personnellement sur le
fait qu'ils doivent ou l'opportunité de
partir pas pour le moment en tout cas